heute hier bei Bilder knappen wir uns
mal die klimakleber vor diejenigen die
sich ja immer auf die Straßen kleben die
Gemälde beschädigen die neuerdings dann
auch noch Ministerien Kapern und ja was
denn noch alles noch fragt man sich ja
und das eben genau das wollen wir einen
dieser Klima Kleber selber fragen jetzt
hier gleich bei Bild live
[Applaus]
Setzungen Blockaden Sachbeschädigungen
es ist die Woche der klimaproteste es
ist die nächste Stufe hin zu Eskalation
bereits am Sonntag Kapern klimakaoten
das Gebäude in dem der deutsche
Weltklima gibt für Tag kleben sich am
Eingang fest Gerechtigkeit weltweit
skandieren die Demonstranten und fordern
jetzt im Inneren des Gebäudes spricht
der Kanzler als plötzlich Feueralarm
ausgelöst wird
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der Protest wird schließlich von der
Polizei aufgelöst
Montagmorgen die Woche beginnt die
klimakaoten kommen und stürmen das
Bundesfinanzministerium schaffen es
sogar bis ins Vorzimmer von Christian
Lindner in dem sie sich als
Besuchergruppe ausgeben
in diesem Moment besetzen etwa 30
Aktivisten das Finanzministerium sie
wollen auf die missliche
Schuldensituation des globalen Südens
aufmerksam machen Deutschland spielt
dabei eine wichtige Rolle
Dienstag
Bundesverkehrsministerium die Aktivisten
von scientist Rebellion beschmieren das
Bundesministerium mit Rote Bete Saft
blockieren die Straßen rund um das
Gebäude Mittwoch die Zentrale des
VW-Konzerns in Wolfsburg auch hier
Sachbeschädigungen die Chaoten werfen
Politik und Industrie Versagen in der
Klimapolitik vor Donnerstagmorgen
Berliner Berufsverkehr klimaaktivisten
der Gruppe letzte Generation kleben sich
an der Straße fest blockieren den
Berufsverkehr fünf Aktionen in einer
Woche was passiert als nächstes
und bei Bild live jetzt einer dieser
Klima Kleber Jakob Bayer Pressesprecher
von der letzten Generation schönen guten
Tag bei Bild live guten Tag
ich glaube wir spinnen auf keinen Fall
wir steuern gerade auch eine absolute
Klimakatastrophe zu die Regierung
spricht immer noch von 1,5 Grad die
werden mit definitiv reißen wir steuern
auch mit drei bis vier Grad heißere Welt
zu und damit auch mit Zukunft in der wir
im flugkatastrophen und Hunger werden
natürlich schon gestellt weil wir schon
der Meinung sind dass relativ viele
Deutsche das glaube ich glauben nämlich
dass sie spinnen glauben sie das nicht
Entschuldigung wir haben schon den
Eindruck dass relativ viele Menschen in
Deutschland hier glauben genau das
nämlich dass sie eigentlich ein bisschen
Spinnen merken Sie das nicht auch dass
das irgendwie aus der Gesellschaft
zurückkommen zu Ihnen
wir haben über die vergangenen Jahre
alles versucht die waren mit Fridays for
future mit 1,4 Millionen Menschen auf
der Straße wir haben Petitionen
unterschrieben werden
zivilgesellschaftliches Engagement
betrieben das Ergebnis davon waren
verfassungsschutzwidriges
Klimaschutzpaket weil dieses
Klimaschutzpaket zukünftige Generationen
nicht schützt wir haben jetzt einen sehr
kurzes Zeitfenster dass ich sehr schnell
schließt das sagen nicht wir das sagt
der das sagt der Weltklimarat wenn wir
jetzt nicht handeln dann ist es
irgendwann zu spät wie alt sind sie wie
alt sind sie herbei ja
Entschuldigung wie alt sind Sie Herr
Bayer ich bin 29 und mit 29 glauben sie
dass sie schon alle Mittel alles alles
in ihrem Leben versucht haben wir leben
ja in der Demokratie könnte man sich zur
Wahl stellen da könnte man in der Partei
gehen da könnte man mit Argumenten
kämpfen mit 29 Jahren sind sie schon am
Ende
ich denke es geht nicht um meine
persönliche Lebensspanne und was ich
persönlich ganz direkt schon alles
versucht hat sondern dass wir ein
Zeitfenster haben welches sich gerade
schließt wir haben noch zwei bis drei
Jahre unsere Welt beginnt gerade in
Flammen aufzugehen wir haben es dieses
Jahr gesehen die Sächsische Schweiz seit
Wochen lang gebrannt deutschlandweit
sind die Flüsse ausgetrocknet das
passiert alles jetzt schon wo die Welt
sich noch nicht um drei bis vier Grad
erhitzt hat ja das ist das ist der
entscheidende Zeitrahmen wir müssen
jetzt handeln wenn wir jetzt nicht
handeln wenn wir wenn wir es nicht
schaffen so sehr zu stören dass die
Politik so unter Druck gesetzt wird dass
wir jetzt entsprechende Maßnahmen
bekommen dann ist es irgendwann zu spät
deswegen müssen wir zum Protest vorm
greifen die leider auch unangenehm sind
keiner von uns tut das gerne aber es ist
besser als in der Welt zu leben wo wir
nicht genug zu essen haben werden Sie
sagen sie müssen in diesen in diese Art
von Protest aber genau das ist eben die
Frage warum versuchen Sie es nicht
einfach mal damit die Menschen zu
überzeugen die Bürger hinter sich zu
bringen und nicht einfach so lange sie
Fotografen zu stressen und zu stören
sondern einfach mal zu versuchen mit
guten Argumenten die Menschen auf ihre
Seite zu ziehen
wir gehen gerade in Berlin auf die
Straßen mit zwei ganz konkreten
Forderungen und zwar einmal der
Forderung nach der Wiedereinführung des
19 Euro Tickets und einem Tempolimit von
100 km/h auf deutschen Autobahnen das
sind beides Forderungen die einen großen
Rückhalt in der Bevölkerung haben beides
Forderungen die sofort massiv CO2
einsparen würden und gleichzeitig den
Menschen zugute kommen würden aber
Demokratie kann man solche Dinge ja dann
auch beschließen aber ein bisschen
Geduld muss man dann vielleicht auch
einfach haben den demokratischen Prozess
dann auch durchzuziehen nur weil man
eine Idee gut findet und weil man die
durchsetzen will kann man sich doch
nicht einfach auf die Straße setzen und
alles blockieren und sagen ich will das
jetzt so das ist doch ein bisschen
kindisch
ich weiß nicht ob sie mir gerade
zugehört haben ja habe ich wir müssen
natürlich Geduld haben aber wenn das
Zeitfenster zwei bis drei Jahre sind
dann ist das der Zeitrahmen indem wir
noch handeln können das müssen wir ernst
nehmen und im in der Demokratie ist
jetzt viele Ungehorsam durchaus ein
legitimes Mittel wir haben in den
letzten Jahren alles versucht wenn du
das nicht ausreicht und wenn das
Zeitfenster so gering ist und die
Konsequenzen auf die wir zusteuern wenn
wir jetzt nicht handeln so massiv sind
Milliarden Menschen werden sterben dann
müssen wir jetzt zu protestvollen
greifen die Druck erzeugen können damit
wir diese Maßnahmen die wir jetzt so
dringend brauchen irgendwie noch
erreichen können mein Eindruck ist dass
sich die Leute nicht mit ihnen
solidarisieren verbünden sondern dass
sie das Abstoßen finden mehrheitlich was
sie machen und dass das eher
kontraproduktiv ist daher ist es nicht
ihr Eindruck dass sie bisher nichts
erreicht haben im Gegenteil
also wir sind im Januar zum ersten Mal
in Berlin auf die Straßen gegangen
damals mit 30 Menschen und haben eine
bundesweite Debatte damals über das
Essen rettengesetz ausgelöst wir sind
dann
zurückgegangen Deutschland weiter am
Vorträge gehalten und sind immer mehr
geworden das heißt die die Bewegung
wächst wir haben immer mehr Reaktionen
aus der Politik und wir werden es auch
auf den Straßen bei dem Blockaden dass
wir immer mehr Zuspruch auch bekommen
natürlich gibt es viel Kritik aber es
gibt auch immer wieder Menschen die
sagen danke dass Sie das macht wir
müssen jetzt was Handeln danke dass Sie
diesen gut aufbringt am Ende brauchen
wir Maßnahmen diesen Erfolg hatten wir
bisher noch nicht aber das das führt bei
uns dazu dass wir sagen okay natürlich
dann müssen wir jetzt weitermachen wir
brauchen Maßnahmen und gleichzeitig
liegt es in der Hand der Regierung die
Regierung kann diese einfachsten
Maßnahmen jetzt sofort umsetzen und wir
haben von Anfang an immer kommuniziert
sobald diese leicht umsetzbare Maßnahmen
umgesetzt werden werden wir die Straßen
sofort verlassen
apropos Regierung gehen sie eigentlich
wählen unterstützen sie den
demokratischen Prozess oder sagen Sie
nein Demokratie ist hier fehl am Platz
natürlich unterstützt sich die
Demokratie und wie schon gesagt hat ist
der zivile Ungehorsam durchaus ein
legitimes Mittel in der Demokratie aber
gehen Sie wählen
wenn wir aber sehen dass das wählen dass
das ein Kreuz machen alle vier Jahre auf
einem Zettel nicht ausreicht dann müssen
wir schauen wie wir die Demokratie
ergänzen können und ich denke was
wichtig ist dass wir Menschen
zusammenkommen in BürgerInnen reden in
denen wir gemeinsam entscheiden weil so
wie es gerade läuft trifft die Politik
nicht mal die einfachsten Maßnahmen die
den Menschen auch den Menschen die dort
morgens in den Staus stehen zugute
kommen würden
na sie nehmen für sich in Anspruch für
die Mehrheit zu sprechen die Mehrheit
ist aber gerade gewählt egal ob einem
das gerade passt mit dieser
Ampelkoalition oder nicht es gibt auch
von anderer Seite sehr sehr viel Protest
und sehr sehr viel Wut im Moment auf
diese und über diese Regierung wie weit
wollen Sie gehen wenn sie sagen das
Zeitfenster aus ihrer Sicht das schließt
sich immer weiter riskieren sie
Menschenleben
ja also wie gesagt das Zeitfenster das
sage nicht ich das sagt der weltklimaat
das sagen die Wissenschaftlerinnen die
gehen und wir für uns ist die rote Linie
immer dort wo wir die Gewaltfreiheit
verlassen würden wir achten bei allen
unseren Aktionen dass wir friedlich
respektvoll und gewaltfrei bleiben das
werden wir immer beibehalten wir werden
aber weiterhin auch immer entschlossen
sein und schauen wo wir den größten
Druck auf die Regierung ausüben können
ich finde ihr Verhalten schon jetzt
nicht besonders respektvoll in vielen
Momenten aber trotzdem nehme ich Ihnen
dieses Versprechen gerne ab und nehme
sie da beim Wort also Menschenleben
werden nicht riskieren das ist werden
nicht riskiert das ist die rote Linie
für Sie persönlich in diesem Protest
danke
was wir mit unseren Aktionen machen ist
dass wir das Leben schützen wollen und
deswegen werden wir auch in unserem
Aktionen darauf achten dass keiner dabei
zu Schaden kommt aber ja danke für das
Gespräch hier Danke schön danke Ihnen
[Musik]